and I remembered a story and it really
affected me years ago my mother was born
in Montreal worked at a company called
Kitty's hogs and she's to come home and
tell my brother and I cuz they pay them
every week on Thursday morning she'd
always invest a third of her paycheck
into bail bonds with coupons she'd
always say to me boys never spend the
principal just the interest and never
ever ever ever buy a security that
doesn't pay a dividend and you know back
in those days
stocks paid higher dividends than the
bonds so example you know Bell Canada
had a 6% yield on its five-year paper
and bonds the stock yield at 7 to entice
people to take the risk to own an equity
and we got lost somewhere between the
50s and the 60s and 70s and we actually
thought that it was a good investment to
buy a stock that didn't pay a dividend
which to me is insane so anyways I I
wanted to found a firm on that my
mother's basic concept because you know
she died a few years ago and I was
executive for her state and I looked at
the portfolio which she never shared
with anybody but 40 years compounded
dividends and bonds you know 73% of the
markets returns over the last 40 years
came from dividends not capital
appreciation and she knew that
intuitively so that's how we built the
foundation of O'Leary funds we listened
to mom we don't own a single security
that doesn't pay a dividend I will never
buy a stock in my life that doesn't pay
a dividend it's not returning cash to me
it's a speculation and if a manager
can't send me cash I'm not interested
often your family will come to you your
cousin your uncle your sister saying
please invest in my business you've got
to differentiate between family friends
and money you've got to be careful that
you don't get yourself in a situation
where you lose your money because you
got emotionally involved that's a very
big piece of advice because I've done it
the wrong I've put everybody's made
mistakes as investor that's one of the
ones I made in the early times I never
make again you just watched two amazing
clips I'm Kevin O'Leary and take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]